more predictions coming out of Davos
another prediction promise or threat
there's going to be a big Cyber attack
we're here today to share the findings
of the world economic forums uh Global
Security Outlook report 2023.
this is a result of research in
collaboration with the forms communities
and our partner Accenture in which we've
interviewed and sought input from over
300 Executives globally the most
striking finding that we found is that
93 percent of cyber leaders
and 86 percent of cyber Business Leaders
believe that the geopolitical
instability makes a catastrophic cyber
event likely in the next two years a
catastrophic cyber event is likely in
the next years maybe it is maybe it
isn't
are these people going to stop it if
they they can't stop it they don't seem
quite so omnipotent as they present
themselves